hello everyone I am very very excited to
watch the official Last of Us trailer
um also if you look really tired it's
because I am I've been traveling like
non-stop for the last week I am
exhausted but still very excited to be
here
um
I'm like kind of nervous because I'm so
excited about watching this I have had a
journey with the show where I've been
like why does it need to exist the
game's so good the first game is one of
the best stories I think I ever told let
alone video game stories it's incredible
why does it need a TV show and then as
time has gone on I'm like you know what
I do want more of it
um I definitely hope there are a couple
of differences uh things to keep people
who played the games a little bit
surprised
um but I think what I'm really looking
for here does not really align with that
what I really hope to see in this
trailer
is chemistry between Joel and Ellie I
think if you don't buy how much they
care about each other well how much Joel
loves Ellie then it's gonna be hard to
sell the entire premise of the last of
us or what that Journey exactly is so
that's what I'm looking for uh I thought
that the teaser trailer was absolutely
beautiful so I'm expecting more things
that you know look like this straight
out of the games which is always awesome
maybe some more stuff about the
fireflies we saw a little bit of that
last time in some of the World building
shots so yeah what I'm really looking
for is Joel and Ellie I think that
they're both incredible actors
um I'm cool with the costing as long as
they're great at their jobs which I
believe that they are then
you know I don't mind if they look
different to to the video games that's
my take
um all right let's do it I don't know
why I feel nervous it's weird okay
if you don't think there's hope for the
world
my mother going on such a good shot
we haven't seen the world
so you don't know
keep going for family
Sarah no
the cargo
foreign
why are you so important
somewhere out west
they're working on a cure she's really
impressed almost the fact that I didn't
turn into a monster she's doing great
there's so much as twitches
that's really good it's so nice to see
her um be cheeky
oh my God
say what I said
you got any advice on the best way west
yeah go east
you've come this far
and you know what's out there
God this is so pretty you're not gonna
scare us
scared who
[Music]
Ops
[Music]
I have chills
any of us could have ever imagined
that's Ashley Johnson
[Music]
be careful who you put your faith in
her father to her songs
oh my God
this looks unbelievable
dude
I'm so glad they got that sound design
right holy crap
there are so many like the shots of
David's men
yeah I thought it was Troy so that's
that's David's men for sure
and there's uh is he Troy Baker that's
awesome having Ashley as
uh look like Sarah's mom there as well I
love that they did that I love that
they're included that's so awesome this
is
a beautiful trailer
um
loads of obviously shots of uh things
that are literally one-to-one to the
games which is probably what gave me
chills like that's so cool to see
um and that's what I was looking for so
I kind of feel like I should watch it
again out of curiosity and I'm thinking
maybe I watch it a second time from the
perspective of if I'm just looking at it
as a piece so let's let's do that I
usually don't but the first time I was
like show me the references I want to
see yay
so maybe the second time what I'm going
to do is try to look at it as a trailer
for a TV show right see how much story
we get
try and
like like analyze how I think somebody
who's not familiar with the last of us
would feel about it so I'm gonna put
that hat on and watch through it one
more time
if you don't think there's hope for the
world
expensive is this
I'm seeing the world
so you don't know
keep going for family
I'm not family that's gonna make me cry
there's no way it's not cargo I think
that's a great opening for people who
might not be familiar tickets and it's a
great that dialogue the conversation
there
Somewhere Out West they're working on a
cure I think what really impressed them
was the fact that I didn't turn into a
monster you see so much as twitches
okay
I think it sets it up really well
actually
obviously Take On Me is a great choice
[Applause]
you got any advice on the best way west
yeah go east
you've come this far
and you know what's out there yeah this
is a good trailer this is a good trailer
scared him
[Music]
oh my God I can't wait
you have a greater purpose than any of
us could have ever imagined
beautiful be careful who you put your
faith in
it might not be her father she was Sons
[Music]
unbelievable my God you trust me
to do
yep it's very good even if you try and
look at it as like a trailer just to
sell a story
the fact that that's really the only
time that you actually fully see a
clicker is a really interesting choice
as well like they mostly like hint at
them and you know have Ellie do like a
fake
transformation love seeing a humor there
um I think this is a good trailer even
for people who may not
um be familiar this is
it's I have chills and I feel emotional
for some reason and I don't know why I
guess it's because there are so many
emotions tied to that game
um
I have so much faith in this is my
biggest concern
obviously the fact that it's a
collaboration between naughty dog and
the creator of Chernobyl and it's on HBO
which definitely has a different caliber
than a lot of the other streaming
networks gives me a lot of faith but I'm
so scared of being excited about things
based on trailers these days like I try
not to especially by filming TV are
concerned
um but
it just looks so good it's so
detail and dense and um
I think the performance is a fantastic
just in this I love Pedro Pascal I think
he's a great actor and it's nice to see
him
outside of a suit for a while very cool
to see Ashley and Troy I mean the cost
in general is awesome so yeah I I wasn't
even sure if I was gonna watch it
originally again because I was like but
I've already played the game what do I
need the story for and
yeah I think that maybe watching it
passively will make me even feel more
strongly about it at this point I don't
know they're doing a great job marketing
it uh let's take a look at some comments
shall we if they get Joel and Ellie's
relationship right the show will be a
huge success I mean that's not a
guarantee but I really do care about
that and I liked the way it looked
in the trailer but they didn't give us
too much of an indication of how that
relationship is going to grow definitely
it's scenery some of the shots look like
they're right out of the video game this
looks unreal absolutely agree with that
the show better start off like the first
20 minutes of the game I am definitely
expecting it to
I'm expecting the opening to be pretty
much identical and what a good opening
it is
um
yeah I wonder if I can get my parents to
watch this because I I do play some
games in front of my parents but I've
never played the last of us in front of
them
and I know that Troy said that the
context of The Last of Us hits different
now that he has a son
which he didn't when he first started
playing Joel it looks really good I'm
super excited and nervous on behalf of
my own excitement to be perfectly honest
would love to know what you guys think
uh I'm for sure gonna watch it I will
never guarantee that I'll watch the
whole thing but if I like the first
episode I'll just keep watching and I
tend to cut off TV shows really fast if
I don't like them because I could be
playing video games instead you know but
uh
it looks good
can't wait